[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHASE IRON EYES:
[SPEAKING LAKOTA]
That means that I consider
you all my friends.
[SPEAKING LAKOTA]
I'm very happy and
honored to be here,
and my name is Chase Iron Eyes.
And I'm excited to be here.
I really-- the
energy is great here.
From the time that we arrived
here, I could feel the energy,
and I really want to
thank those who took time
out of their schedules,
out of their days, those
amongst the Google
American Indian network,
to make this possible
from the time
we arrived at our parking spots.
You know, there's
little signs that
say, Parking Reserved or has
a little picture of Yoda that
says, Do Not Park.
Park-- how does he say it?
How Yoda talks.
We're reserving it
for Chase Iron Eyes.
So I want to tell you
a little bit about--
I was born in the Black Hills
of what is now South Dakota.
Some of you have
probably been there.
It's where Mt.
Rushmore is and so forth.
And my mother moved us back
to the Standing Rock Nation
or the Standing
Rock Reservation,
where I grew up there my
whole life, until I was 19.
And then I went to college.
So growing up on a reservation,
a modern American Indian
reservation at a time in this--
I was born in 1978,
and the reservations
were created kind of as
military forts and prison camps
during the late 1870s, when--
and it's important
to start there,
because today, September 5th,
2017, it is now September 5th,
1877, is about a year after
the Battle of Little Big Horn.
It's popularly known
as Custer's Last Stand.
We don't think Custer made
any kind of last stand,
but Crazy Horse
surrendered in 1877.
And on this day in
1877, Crazy Horse
was assassinated by his
own people, by my people.
And that ties right into
what Standing Rock, what
the water protected
movement was all about
and what it is all about.
And that is our
path to liberation.
I wanted to tell you
about Crazy Horse,
because he would say things
like, people or a man
must have a vision,
and they have
to seek that vision to the
deepest blues of the skies.
He would say things like,
it's a good day to die.
And at first glance, those
seem quite shocking, maybe,
but when you study
divinity, or you're
trying to commune with
the divine consciousness
in any kind of ceremonial or
metaphysical or ritual way,
whether it's meditation
or whatever it is for you,
you come to the
conclusion that any day,
really, when you are united
with the divine consciousness--
God, Allah, or
whether it's the Hindu
tradition, the Yogic
tradition, whatever it is--
any day is a good day to die,
because death is not a death.
Death is only a change.
It's as much as part of
life, and people felt that
at Standing Rock.
For us out there, it
wasn't a difficult choice
to have to say to
ourselves, we are
going-- we are being called
to risk our liberty, perhaps,
our life, our earning
potential, our reputations,
our professional reputations.
Right now, my law
license is at risk.
It's on the line.
I'm being charged with a
felony, with inciting a riot,
and I'm facing a five-year
maximum prison sentence
right now.
But my story started on
the Standing Rock Nation,
the Standing Rock Reservation.
And when you grow up in those
environments, where there
was a very premeditated
and deliberate attempt
to kind of erase the
original spiritual dignity,
self-determination,
self-reliance, self-esteem,
and fortunately,
we are survivors.
And we survived a
genocide, a Holocaust,
all up and down the hemisphere.
We survived slavery
and so forth.
We know-- those of us
who are paying attention
know our history in
what we should now
be considering our homeland.
It's not just our country.
But I didn't--
I grew up inside that
environment, where
it's very much an
imposed poverty culture,
and all of the quality
of life indicators
are kind of akin
to what would be
present in a third world
country like Haiti and so forth.
There's a lot of challenges,
a lot of obstacles.
There's also just what I like
to call unconquerable dignity
and unconquerable hope.
And it's evident when the
poorest people in the world--
put some quotations
around the word, "poor--"
materially impoverished,
deliberately, we
made a choice to
stand up on behalf
of a universal element, a sacred
element that we call water.
In our cosmology, in our
methodology, we have--
some of you have heard
the term, [LAKOTA]..
Have you heard that term?
You've all heard
the term, [LAKOTA]..
So that's the Lakota language.
And in order to say
something like [LAKOTA],,
or really to gain
an understanding
of the origin of
that phrase, you
have to go back to one of
our first creation stories.
We have Lakota words for these
stories, what the West would
sometimes call myths.
I mean it's not wrong
to call them myths,
but that kind of has a
certain connotation like it's
a fairy tale, or it's
folklore, and so forth.
It sounds like the opposite of
what the scientific method is
and what empiricism is.
It sounds like a superstition.
But for us, these
are called knowledge.
They're called [LAKOTA],,
the first beginnings.
These stories are
called [LAKOTA]..
These are things that I
learned from my elders.
And there is a different
kind of story that's not--
it's not like creation stories.
They're just
stories like fables.
And those are called [LAKOTA].
And when you say
the words, [LAKOTA],,
you have to ask yourself,
where does water come from?
Just think about
that for a second.
Where does water come from?
We know it's composed of a
couple of hydrogen molecules
and an oxygen molecule.
We know certain
things about water.
We know that when
the spring comes,
it thaws in the mountains,
and it creates its own path.
It's being held in the
embrace of Mother Earth.
And because the seasons
renew themselves,
this water is able
to find its way
through the mountains,
every spring, every freshet,
every creek, every stream,
even to raging rivers.
They are all one water,
and all of that water
is flowing to every ocean.
There is really only one
water in our universe.
That includes even the rain
cycles, the evaporation cycle.
It's all connected.
But according to our--
just this one cosmology,
there was a time of--
the English word for it is
darkness, but our word for it
is han, H-A-N.
I don't know the true
etymology of the word, han,
but I know from my son peppering
me with questions, because he
says, Dad, is han nothing?
And I said, no, han is
definitely not nothing.
Darkness is not nothing.
Dark matter, dark
energy, whatever
is holding the entire
incomprehensible,
infinite expansion that is our
known universe is not nothing.
Eons ago, more than geologic
eons ago, there was han,
and in that time, the
foremost spirit had a name.
It still has a name,
and its name is Inyan.
Now, Lakota cosmology
personifies Inyan
and calls him a he.
Again, when I tell these
stories to my daughters,
they don't necessarily agree
with assigning a gender
to a spirit.
So I use the word, "it," or
maybe just the name, Inyan,
because Inyan really
doesn't have a gender.
We call it a he, traditionally.
Inyan became lonely,
and Inyan begin to spin.
And it spun so
violently that it caused
an intergalactic,
universal explosion.
And in that explosion,
Inyan created
a disc, a globe, a sphere, and
Inyan sacrificed its own blood
to create this disc and
to cause this creation.
But it had to create of itself,
and Inyan's blood is water.
So Inyan, all of its
powers-- remember,
he's the foremost spirit--
flowed from him, or it,
into water and into this
plane, this disc now
that is Mother Earth.
And Mother Earth
wasn't the Mother Earth
that we know right now.
It was uninhabitable
at the time.
But his powers flowed
into the water,
into the blue dome around
Mother Earth, the atmosphere,
and so forth.
So when we say that water is
life, this is what we mean.
These are the deep--
you know, deep connotations
that come from saying,
water is life, or [LAKOTA],,
or water is sacred.
It brings into being, brings
forth our very cosmology.
So we have a very real, a
sacred connection to water,
and so do you.
Everybody's walking around with
75% of their body is water.
So one last note on
that cosmovision,
because those things
are important,
especially in a
time like 2017, when
we have crossed certain
areas of the digital divide.
And we're going to pursue
even more powerful areas
of the digital experience,
the digital divide.
And we have to remember our own
sanctity, our own connection
to Mother Earth, to the
sacred sites, to the waters,
to the cosmos.
Now, some of you have
heard of a sweat lodge.
Have you heard of a sweat lodge?
One last note about that,
and I tell you these things,
so you can get a
sense of who I am,
who we are, the blood
in the cosmovision
that I was born into.
When we have a
sweat lodge, so when
Inyan sacrificed
itself and its power,
he sacrificed his own place
as the foremost spirit
and its power flowing
into the waters
and into the blue dome
around Mother Earth.
Inyan shriveled up
and became a rock.
He became a hard rock,
and you find-- you
see him all over the planet.
Some people would
just see a rock.
So it would see an
inanimate object,
would think that
human beings would
have some sort of
pretentious right
to a certain dominion
over these inanimate
objects, even the animate ones.
But we see what we call
[LAKOTA],, or the oldest God.
And when we go into a sweat
lodge, you take Inyan,
you take these rocks.
[LAKOTA] is just
another name Inyan.
And you heat them up.
You combine them with fire, and
they become glowing, red hot.
And you take them
into a sweat lodge
that is ceremonially and
symbolically appointed.
This whole talk could
be about our cosmology,
but I just want to end on this.
There are 16 entities that we
respect in Lakota cosmovision
or mythology or religion.
Just like Joseph Campbell
says, everyone's--
mythology is just other
people's religions.
So in ours, there's
these 16 deities.
And Inyan used to be number
one, but now he's number four.
But when we bring in Inyan,
the hot rocks, into the lodge,
and we bring in water,
that's Inyan's blood.
And we reunite Inyan
with its blood,
and we pour the
water on the rocks.
And you hear these
ancient, older
than time sounds,
universal sounds,
natural and elemental sounds.
And that's on my journey
that I've been on
in trying to free the water
protectors and making sure
nobody does a single day
in prison or in jail.
I've been talking a lot.
I've been talking a lot about
the word, "colonization,"
and how those of us who are
reared in American education
systems or Canadian
education systems
or educational
institutions of the West,
we think of colonization
as something
that's now called white people
colonizing and enslaving
brown people and black people.
It's OK.
That's a trope.
That's a way to think about it.
That's a way to
experience that word.
I know, because I grew
up on a reservation.
But as I expanded my
horizons, put myself
in those educational
institutions, whether that
was undergraduate training or
law school or whatever it was,
I found out that white
people is not a real word.
I found this out when I ran
for the United States Congress
as well.
There's no such thing as that.
There's a such thing
as Germans and Russians
and people of
Scandinavian descent,
Norwegians all over
North Dakota, Irish,
even though Irish don't
consider themselves
white in that demographic.
But I began to explore
the word, "colonization,"
as it applied to
those demographics,
because what I found out is that
everybody had been separated.
There was this process
of abstraction,
a separation, a division of
our mind from our spirit,
our heart from our intellect,
our human connection
to something so basic
as our food source.
Who here among us has a sacred
relationship with their food
source right now?
That's right.
There's people
raising their hands,
because we are seeking
that reconnection.
That's why I think so many
people went to Standing Rock.
people respond to song.
They respond to the drum.
They respond to what the West,
again, would call ritual,
but we just call it
ceremony or protocol.
And some of these songs that
descend from our cosmologies,
they don't have words.
They're older than literacy.
Not even literacy, but
the oral tradition.
And they're inspired by
the elements themselves,
by the wind, for instance, or
the birds, the winged nation.
These songs are
inspired and gifted
from other groups of the
four-legged community,
whether that's wolves
or coyotes or what.
For us, nature is our media.
Truly, nature is our media.
And I think that I'm here at
Google, the world's leader,
the harbinger, the harbinger
really laying the foundations,
the archetypes of
how we are going
to color our
personalities, how we
are going to perceive
our realities,
how we are going to
connect with each other,
with our surroundings,
how we are going
to interface with the universe.
Very, very powerful concepts
and challenges are coming,
and what I know is that we are
sitting amongst each other,
and we are sitting amongst
people, who have the capacity
to appreciate a term like,
water is life, or [LAKOTA]..
I wanted to start
there, and then
talk a little bit about what
happened at Standing Rock.
But before I start
there, how many people
had a chance to go out to
Standing Rock in the room?
That's pretty good.
Like I said before, I had
finished law school sometime
in 2007, and we did not move
back to the Standing Rock
Reservation until 2014.
And it was a strange experiment
to bring our kids back
to that environment,
because they had never
lived there before.
And it was-- we're
thankful today
that we went back,
that we came back home.
It wasn't until two years
later that I began my run
for the United States Congress.
And actually, in some
synchronistic way,
it was April 1st,
and I was going
to seek the nomination, the
endorsement of the North Dakota
Democratic Party.
And I ran into
this large caravan.
We're talking 100
horses, runners,
like a caravan of cars
a couple miles long,
and I was in a hurry.
Like I'm always running
late for things.
I was in a hurry, and I
came up behind this caravan,
and I thought, oh,
no, I'm going to be
late for the Democratic
Convention, where I've
got to receive the nomination.
So we got to go through
this whole process.
So I had to stop
what I was doing,
turn around, and go all the way
around a different route, which
was almost certain
to make me late.
But I made it.
But it was a sign
to me that I was not
going to be able to ignore this
Dakota Access Pipeline issue.
And I remember thinking,
in the community,
we didn't quite know
how we were going
to deal with this pipeline or
how we were going to fight it.
And if it wasn't for
technology, if it wasn't
for those platforms, that
kind of democratized media,
democratized journalism,
and just the ability
to get your story out in the way
that you wanted to get it out,
we would not have
been able to generate
the attention or the
effort, or we would not
have been able to spark
this international spiritual
monument is what one of
our elders refers to it as.
It's a spiritual monument
that lives in our hearts
and in our minds.
Everywhere I go, people know
what "water is life" means.
But water is life--
it is more than just
a saying or a mantra.
It calls into question
the very meaning of terms
like, "civilization," the
very meaning of terms like,
"progress," and how
those concepts have
been defined for us,
but for a long time,
by these processes
of separation.
Before, when I was
talking about separating
our spirit from our mind,
and our human experience
with the sacred, whether
that's a food source
or sacred sites or the cosmos.
I mean, if you go
back far enough
in any one of your
lineages, you will
find that you are descended
from original people,
original nations, who had
these sacred covenants.
And now, today, we
think of those people
as indigenous people.
And that's OK, because
indigenous people
is an international
legal term of art,
kind of like tribal nation.
But through my
journey, I've been
able to make the
connection that we weren't
the only ones colonized.
Europe was colonized way before
they got to our continent,
and that separation
had occurred.
And people are trying to
reconnect to that right
now, in our country,
in our homeland.
I really-- I've been able to
find that out just in my last
few months of travel is
that we are yearning--
I like to say that our spirits
are grieving for ceremony,
because intrinsically, we
are spiritual beings that
are seeking this
liberation, that are seeking
to be able to transcend either
the limits we were born into,
our bodies, and our
language, and certainly,
seeking to liberate
from those labels
and other human constructs
like race, like religion,
and so forth.
And I think those of us who
are in these circles, who
are part of this
spiritual evolution,
or certainly, a
social evolution,
those of us who are
on this trajectory
are seeing each other.
That energy is resonating
with all of us,
and it's being challenged
right now politically.
You can see the separation,
the hate, the division,
and the fear that is
being perpetrated.
It's being pushed out, and it
finds it homes in some places.
But those of us who are guided
by love, guided by compassion,
guided by peace and prayer
and dignity and bravery,
we know that we cannot back
down from any injustice,
no matter what the odds are.
And at Standing Rock,
right now, there
are 843 people, who are
facing criminalization,
facing criminalization, because
a private military contractor
was able to instigate
corporate-sponsored and
state-executed
violence and rights
violations against peaceful
and prayerful water protectors.
Those of you who followed
the entire struggle know
that not once did we
instigate violence,
did we instigate aggression,
did we do any kind of assault
or assert ourselves in that way.
And it's a very conscious
and strategic choice
that those of us,
who can see that we
are at risk of being oppressed,
that we are at risk of having
our water poisoned
or privatized,
that what constitutes
law and order
and what constitutes
our jurisprudence
does not have a place
for sacred water
or even water as water quality.
It doesn't have a place
for healthy ecosystems.
And indeed, we are people
who believe and know
that these are natural rights.
These are birth rights.
These aren't rights that
descend from synthetic bodies
of man-made law, and
underline and score the man,
the patriarchy made law there.
So we are really
on this front line,
and we were able to see
it at Standing Rock.
We were able to see this
group called TigerSwan, which
called me and my
children jihadists,
because we were engaging prayer
and connections in spirit
to the land itself, and that
it was able to motivate people.
It was able to activate
part of their consciousness.
This same thing happened
during the ghost dance era.
I've said that we are the
ghost dancers of our time,
but what has happened at
Standing Rock and what
continues to happen,
their foretelling of what
kind of human rights,
natural rights, civil rights,
constitutional rights,
what sort of rights
private military corporations
are willing to violate
in our own country.
That's what's
extremely significant
and why we are asking people
to turn their attention back
to the water protectors,
especially those of us who
are being criminalized, those of
us who are facing prison time.
It's very important,
because you have
to think about there's
lawyers in the room here.
And I'm a lawyer, and
when law enforcement
is able to say that they are
simply upholding law and order,
most people stop their
inquiry at that statement,
because law and order carries
a weight of legitimacy to it.
But at Standing Rock, we
were really trying to pierce,
and sometimes in law,
we talk about piercing
the corporate veil.
We were trying to pierce
this corporeal veil and ask,
who is defining and designing
the contours of law and order?
Who says that it's illegal for
somebody to stand and pray,
sometimes in a
public right of way?
Who says that it
is legal to force
one population at
gunpoint to bear
a risk, cancerous, poisonous
risks to their children's
water, while another
population is not
made to bear those risks?
That's exactly what happened.
Who says that's law and order?
And even Pope Francis,
the wokest pope ever,
would agree, because
in his encyclical,
he's saying things
like, it should
be a sin to poison a river.
Maybe corporations
should be held liable,
and that's a very
powerful concept.
That's going to take us down the
road of corporate personhood.
And when we're talking about
piercing the corporate veil,
we, here in this room,
the leaders of our future,
the leaders of our digital
and spiritual evolution,
we have to take
responsibility and ownership
of what we are doing.
And Google is doing that.
Energy Transfer Partners and
TigerSwan are not doing that.
I say this all the time that
capital without compassion
is uncivilized.
It truly is.
And if we take a look
at Standing Rock,
we have to be
willing to sacrifice.
We have to be willing to
step out of our comfort zones
and to really redefine what
progress is, what civilization
is, and what law and order
is, because we know that law
and order should serve people.
Law and order should
serve Mother Earth.
It should serve our
children's rights
to clean water and
healthy ecosystems.
Currently, it doesn't.
This is why there is a
pipeline at Standing Rock
right now, despite our
most valiant efforts.
And the scope of
Standing Rock is immense.
Just in this room right
here, probably 30%
of this room or better went
to Standing Rock personally.
Not only that, but
on the internet
that Al Gore invented--
this is the only place where
people would get that--
tens of thousands of people gave
of their time, their energy,
their precious
time here on Earth,
and came out there in person.
Truly amazing.
It was just-- it was a
spiritual awakening out there.
The water was calling, and
it's still calling to us.
But online, millions
of people, hundreds
of millions of
people in our country
alone were able
to pay attention.
They were able to
be there in spirit.
They contributed, they donated,
they ran food, blankets, water,
supplies, humanitarian
aid of all kinds
out to those at Standing Rock.
And I don't know--
I would dare to
say that billions
of people around the globe
were able to pay attention.
They were able to be there
in spirit, because this
is the first time that
we were able to transcend
those differences.
There's sometimes those
phenotypic differences
of race, color, creed,
religion, all that stuff.
And to be able to stand
up in truly a selfless act
of compassion, we are
willing to stand up and place
our bodies in
harm's way on behalf
of and in defense of water.
That is powerful.
That is unprecedented
that we were able to--
and I was very much
raised in a family that
was fully cognizant of the
civil rights struggles,
was very cognizant of
the systemic nature,
unjust nature of
some of our systems
that resulted in the Black Lives
Matter movement and so forth.
But this time around, because
indigenous people still
kept alive their sacred
connections to the universe,
and we are still gifted
with those songs,
with those prayers,
with those ceremonies,
with that divine
awareness, we were
able to collectively elevate
global consciousness.
We were able to
change our reality.
And right now, the
state of North Dakota,
who are good people.
I ran for Congress here.
Morton County is maintaining
charges, criminal charges
against peaceful and
prayerful water protectors.
And by doing that, by
maintaining those charges,
they are trying to
preempt and usurp
and to take, to seize the
legal and moral authority
to call somebody a criminal.
It's very important that
we get to that point.
This is why it's so important
that people help us compel.
Put moral, spiritual,
and other pressure,
positive pressure on them
to drop all of these charges
that they are
currently maintaining
against peaceful and
prayerful water protectors.
And I don't know if we're going
to put that up on the screen.
You can either text
"Lakota" to 64336,
or log on to lakotalaw.org.
We are doing-- we are making
tremendous progress, however.
I think we're beyond 30,000
signatures, more than 20,000
of those coming
the old school way.
They're going door
to door, going
to gathering to
gathering, reaching people
where they're at.
And we-- it's
really-- it's an honor
to be able to spin
this little bit of time
with you to let
you know who I am,
the cosmology, and the culture,
the worldview, the way of life
that I was born
into, but still being
able to connect with
anybody, regardless
of what those
classifications are,
because our spirits
are universal.
And we are all spiritually
inclined to seek
those connections and really
to return to the sacred.
And my little girl,
one of my daughters,
she's eight years old--
I was speaking with some Google
folks, who, I understand,
are creating a Lakota
language translate or app
or some other tool.
And I was completely encouraged
to hear that, because
in language is kind of--
we say language
has its own spirit.
And again, we have
another story about how
we got language, received it.
In there is contained the
archetypes, the foundations,
the ways that human beings learn
to even perceive themselves
in the universe, how
they learned to color
their universe, how they learned
to imagine, how they think.
So for Google to be doing
that, which they've already
done for the
Cherokee language, I
was completely
blown away that this
could be-- this is going to
be possible for my daughter
and those of us who are
second language learners.
I was raised learning
English as a first language,
and then it wasn't
until later that I
began to try to learn Lakota.
And when the immersion school
came to the Standing Rock
Nation, to my reservation,
we lived an hour away.
And my little girl was four
years old, so she rode a bus.
We had to take her to this
bus at 6:30 every morning,
and she rode 60 miles one way.
She had a little commute,
little four-year-old,
she commuted with
one of our elders,
who was a teacher at the
Lakota immersion school,
but who was an original
language-- he was
born with the Lakota language.
And so the possibilities
are endless with how we can
unite spirit and technology.
It's part of our evolution.
And it's kind of scary.
It's very, very serious.
Virtual reality is already here.
I have not experienced
it yet, but we
are sitting in a place, where
we are going to determine
our cultural reality.
We are going to do that
as a human species now.
And so for those of
you who are out there,
I wanted to impart a little bit
of this spirit of liberation,
because we can't
forget who we are.
We can't forget
where we come from.
Those things are so important.
It's so important for us
to ask those questions
that philosophers, theologians,
seers, and probably just
homeless people on the
street, poor, righteous
teachers have been
asking themselves
and have been seeking the truth
since the dawn of humanity.
We are truly on the precipice
of a significant time.
And for us at Standing Rock,
for us in the Lakota Nation,
we are fully ready to
embrace any change.
That's all we've ever done.
We've adapted.
We've survived.
And for us to put it
on the line out there
at Standing Rock on behalf of
and in defense of sacred water
wasn't even a question.
I'm looking forward to getting
my charges disposed of,
so I can join the next fight,
and in the process, continuing
to go wherever I'm blessed
to go, wherever people
are listening, wherever people
are seeking those connections.
We're ready to make
those connections.
This is our homeland, and
it's your homeland, too.
This is more than
just your country.
Another thing at the front line
and during the Standing Rock
battle was the concepts
of patriots and terrorists
and who is defining the
contours of those terms
like "patriot" and
"terrorists" and "immigrant."
it's very-- it's powerful.
Language is powerful.
And for us, the
patriot is the mother,
who sacrificed everything
to go protect sacred water,
so her children could
have clean drinking water.
She is not the terrorist.
The patriot isn't
the person that
is extracting a common
resource, such as fossil fuels,
putting at dangerous
risk and peril
another common
resource like water
for the benefit of
their private profit.
That's not the patriot.
That might be the terrorist.
That might be somebody that's
putting us at unnecessary risk.
Standing Rock continues
to be powerful,
and I really want to engage you.
I know I came to Google to
speak and to share and to give
a talk, but I also
came to learn.
I came to meet people.
I came to make connections.
We don't have very long here on
Earth, so we have to stay busy.
We have to be
grateful every day,
whether that's greeting
the sun, or you
might hear the birds sing in
a certain way on your walk,
or you might look at--
you might be blinded by the way
the sun glints off the water
and just catches you.
You might see the sunset.
In those tiny moments, you might
be able to make a connection.
You're able to transcend.
You're able to
make yourself one.
We have another concept
called [LAKOTA]..
It literally means, everything
that is, is my relative.
These are some of
the ways that we
have to begin to partner,
to share our truths,
share our experiences, and
create the kind of reality,
the kind of evolutionary
process that we
want for us and for our
children, our progeny.
We are-- we're facing
existential crises right now,
whether that's the
hurricanes in Houston,
climate change, the whole
Midwest from Montana west
is burning up right now.
Drought-- we just got
over a drought out here.
We've got a nuclear potential
that's very, very real.
Even though-- for some--
I mean, for some reason,
we're able to deal
with that effectively.
We're able to put it
somewhere, and just
continue on with our day.
But I mean just
right now, they're
about to try to declare human
beings illegal, human beings
that have a prior and
original birth right to seek
their destiny here, where
we are at right now.
Some of the original
civilizers of this hemisphere,
when they try to declare an
entire religion taboo and say,
you can log longer
enter our country--
those are the times that the
front line is everywhere.
I know maybe it's hyperbole
to say that we are in a place
right now, where the
battle for the heart
and soul of our
homeland, of our country
is every single
day, every moment,
you have to choose to show up.
Standing Rock is just
one of those moments.
Standing Rock
demands a sacrifice.
I've got to be willing to
go to jail, to stand up,
so other people can
see that water is life.
Water is important.
And I know that that
inspires other people,
because I'm inspired
by those others, who
are led by love and compassion
and bravery and peace
and dignity.
But I wanted to share at
least that much with you,
and thank you all for listening.
Thank you for connecting with
us afterwards and continuing
to stay engaged in the work that
we are doing and the direction
that we want to compel
not only our homeland,
but to compel humanity.
This is the scale and the
scope of our vision now.
We're all part of
this same vision,
so I do want to leave
some time for questions.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: We have two
questions from the Dory.
So, Chase, the
first question is,
when we see and hear changes in
the current administration that
hint at rollbacks at the EPA and
other environmental programs,
how does this affect tribal
protections or agreements
between tribal lands and the US
government, and to what degree?
CHASE IRON EYES: Yes, the
United States currently
holds native nations
or tribal nations
in a state of tutelage
and oppression,
kind of like a
guardian to a ward.
You don't learn these things
when you grow up on the res,
and they don't necessarily
even teach you at law school.
They just teach
you that Congress
has this superior and
plenary authority over you
as an Indian person
or as a tribal nation.
So when they are rolling
back federal laws,
it has a direct and immediate
impact upon native nations,
and that's why
native nations are
willing to push back and say,
look, this law and order that
is being imposed upon
us that is causing us
undue risk is not right.
It holds no legal
or moral authority
and should be challenged.
But the only way to
challenge that right now
is through peace,
prayer, and standing up.
But that's just one thing.
That's just one challenge.
So what happens at
the federal level
has a direct and immediate
impact at the tribal level.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so
much for being here.
I have a question
for you, and that
comes from my own experience
of being at the WTO
ministerial proceedings
back in 1999.
CHASE IRON EYES: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And that
was that I was
talking to a group of
activists, actually.
I used to be an
environmental activist, too.
And it struck me
how you can break up
a mob of people, who think
single-mindedly about something
just through conversation.
And I'm wondering if you or
any of the Standing Rock people
have had a chance to speak
individually one on one
with members of the police
forces or TigerSwan.
And have you seen any
of their humanity?
I mean, how can we break
through to them individually?
CHASE IRON EYES: That's
a very good question.
What was poignant, significant
was this juxtaposition.
When I was on the
front line, and I
was running for the United
States Congress at the time,
so I always wore a mask.
And later, we did that
to protect ourselves
from these private military
contractors that were snatching
your identity with
facial recognition
and lots of other kind of
crazy frontier-like things.
But when I was at
some of these actions,
on the other side
of the front line
would be these
military-ready police.
I mean, they looked like they
were ready to roll into Iraq.
And I looked through
the glass shield,
and I would see friends.
I would see my friends that
I had played basketball
with at the local YMCA,
the Young Men's Christian
Association.
Every other day
at noon, we would
go there to play basketball.
And I would see my friends
on that side of the line,
and I'm on this
side of the line.
And in that little moment,
we were both playing our part
in this drama.
But because I had run for
Congress in North Dakota,
I knew a whole lot of people.
And that was one of the
most important strategies
was to begin to try
to humanize everybody
on either side of this.
struggle, because there is
a certain amount of cover
that people can claim when
they're saying they're
just following orders,
or they're just
upholding law and order.
So it was very important to--
for each side to
humanize each other.
And one way that I did that
was when I was in jail, the day
that I got arrested, the
correctional officers
had been there way too long.
And what I did was I helped
kind of defuse tense situations
so that we weren't putting undue
burden on those people, who
were just doing their job.
And so we-- it's a struggle.
And that's the war
of the narrative
out there on Standing Rock.
Very quickly, I'll
mention that TigerSwan
had begun to issue these media
strategies and these missives,
these documents that
would say things like--
that would make it into local
mainstream news outlets,
saying things like,
local ranchers--
cue the Germans and the
Americans or whatever--
local ranchers in
fear of their lives,
because protesters
are killing livestock.
Like they try to hearken
back these old prejudices
on both sides, and
make it seem like it
was the 1800s out there again.
That's when I very first
started to say, look,
we need to cut through all this
Indian people and white people
dynamic that is being exploited
out here in North Dakota.
And we have to start uniting.
We have to start finding
a way to cut through that
and to unite each other.
Otherwise, this is going
to be a card well played
by these operatives,
and that's kind
of where we're at right now.
In our country, we saw
that whatever they're
willing to do to
us, they're going
to be willing to do to
anybody who stands up
against a company that
wants to poison their water,
or put a nuclear frack waste
dump site wherever you might
live, or destroy some other
aspect of our ecosystem
that doesn't have any legal
protections right now.
We are all going to be called
to stand up at some point.
So it's really, really
important that we
do that, that we come together,
that we humanize each other,
and that's part of my
message is that we do.
We have to liberate from
those differences, perceived
differences, and
yeah, differences
that we are born into as well.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: If you don't mind,
I've got just a couple.
CHASE IRON EYES:
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: First, thank
you for being here.
We appreciate it immensely.
And just the first is
actually just a small example,
but I know that they steepened
the penalties for protest
in North Dakota.
They were successful in that.
Do I also understand
that they almost
passed a law that made it
legal to run over protesters
that were in public roadways?
CHASE IRON EYES:
Yes, that's a very--
so that's why the
energy that we have,
that progressive
people might have,
or those who are on this
trajectory of social
and political evolution
and spiritual evolution--
it's important for us to be
active on all these fronts,
because legislators
create this policy.
And during the No DAPL struggle,
legislators created a policy.
They introduced a law that
would waive tort liability
for motorists who happened to
run through and potentially
kill a protester in a
larger group of protesters,
like exactly what happened
at Charlottesville.
But that law was never passed.
They did pass other
laws that it's
illegal to conceal your identity
in furtherance of a protest,
that any kind of property
damage to commercial activity
would be a felony,
and they even tried
to eliminate tribal gaming.
So when we say the
battle for the heart
and soul of our
country is every day,
we are being tested
right now as a country.
And that's why it's so important
for us to come together.
I've been preaching that
everywhere that I go.
Even when I was running for
the United States Congress,
it was most important,
because that's when--
and we obviously survived Trump.
A lot of us thought
the sky was falling.
But we know now that
we'll survive whatever.
You know what I mean?
That's why we have a
representative democracy,
a republican form of
government, checks and balances,
and judicial supremacy,
and so forth.
We will survive as a
people, but we really
need to concentrate our
efforts on all these aspects
of what I call the front
line, because they have
very real impacts on our lives.
I'm glad that law didn't pass.
There's another law on the
books up there in North Dakota
that it is illegal for
more than, I think,
three Indians to
congregate so that you
can consider them a war party.
And so this is me
in my sweater vest
and bow tie friends
at the coffee shop.
You know what I mean?
AUDIENCE: Second
question-- actually,
if I recall correctly,
and I'm hoping I'm wrong,
and please fact check me, but
the vehicular manslaughter
waiver law I think missed
by only five votes.
Second question is,
have you considered
skipping Congress altogether
and going straight
for the presidency?
[LAUGHTER]
I mean--
[APPLAUSE]
CHASE IRON EYES: You know,
I have considered that.
But I also-- anywhere
that I go, anywhere
that I'm blessed to be,
I can feel this energy.
I can feel that we are
all on the same path here.
Running for the United States
Congress in North Dakota
was an eye-opener.
I was made acutely aware of
how money and other interests
have kind of hijacked
our democracy.
We don't have leaders anymore,
who are guided by conscience
or are seeking a
higher consciousness.
We have politicians that
are forced to raise money.
I spent all of my time
dialing for dollars.
So I know that we
are going to produce
the right kind of conviction
and values and truth seekers,
and those who really are
trying to create a better
planet, those who are guided
by compassion and love
and bravery, I really believe
that we are going to produce
those kind of leaders.
We're in a tough spot right now.
It's very hard.
It's so easy to despair
and just kind of try
to step away from it
and quit showing up.
But we cannot do that.
Like for instance,
I'm flying out to DC
to speak to a progressive
gathering about what
we are going to do about
this political system.
It's not serving
the people anymore.
And it's not serving
Mother Earth,
and we don't have to get
tripped up in the labels.
We just have to be truthful
about what kind of world
we want to create.
And I think we're on this path.
I believe that
anything good that I'm
able to impart that
comes from the substance
that I'm evolving into
that I was raised in,
that we are going
to be able to see
leadership that reflects any
good that I'm able to impart.
I truly believe that.
AUDIENCE: How do you
get past the anger?
CHASE IRON EYES: Yeah.
You mean from the entire
colonization experience
or from the pipeline?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I'm sure,
like I do, you
have generations of
anger embedded in you.
CHASE IRON EYES: Yes.
AUDIENCE: How?
CHASE IRON EYES: So that's
a very good question.
And I think we are
a social experiment.
Our country is the greatest
experiment on the planet.
I believe in our country.
I believe in our homeland.
I believe that we are
the true patriots--
anybody who is
willing to stand up
for sacred water in
the lands and so forth.
And it is true that native
people, the original civilizers
of this continent,
were subjected
to a different kind
of colonization,
the same kind that was
executed everywhere else.
But that expropriation--
it does cause anger.
And I think that's just a stage.
Maybe in pedagogy of the
oppressed or somewhere,
you can learn more about the
stages of grief and coming
to terms.
And I went through that.
I'm not trying to
downplay that whatsoever.
I went through that very, very
heavily in my adolescent years
into my early adulthood
years, and I just
had to go on a journey
of self-discovery.
I don't think
there's avoiding it.
There's just dealing with
it, and you heal from it.
You let the scars
or the wounds scar.
And then, you're able
to evolve from that.
You go from anger to a place
of compassion and bravery,
and so it's very real.
There's no way to deal with it.
You just have to
let the tissue scar.
AUDIENCE: Just one
quick question.
What are the more
pressing issues
maybe for you
personally, and then
more for the tribe as a whole?
Like, obviously,
the criminal thing,
and then [INAUDIBLE] tribes
may be working [INAUDIBLE]??
CHASE IRON EYES: Yes, the most
immediate and pressing issue
is for me to stay out of
prison, for me personally.
I have three kids.
I have a wife that
is a rock star.
She runs the entire clinic
on the Standing Rock Nation.
She's a Stanford grad, so
she's very partial and familiar
to the area here.
So I need to stay out of the
law's hands in that fashion.
That's why we're out here trying
to raise as much awareness
as we can.
But for the tribal
nation, we just
need to renegotiate the
treaty relationship that we
have with the United States.
We are a tripartite citizens.
We are descended from the
original and intrinsic
sovereign authorities
to determine our destiny
in our hemisphere.
But we also have treaties
with the United States.
And now, there's also
the States of the Union,
so I mention those things,
because I want to--
we shouldn't be living in
the level of imposed poverty
that we are living in
on the reservation.
We have tremendous
gifts, knowledges,
and worldviews to share.
We belong as dignified,
upstanding members
of the world of nations.
And so it's part
of my life's work,
part of the work that I was born
into, that my mother taught me
about growing up on
the res by herself,
the single poor working mom, put
me on that path to seek that,
but also to seek it
in a different way.
Seek it in this-- we talk a
lot about peace and dignity.
And we do it--
and prayer.
And we talk about it like
that, because seeking
that prayer, that peace,
and that dignity to know
the power of peace
results in your avail,
your spiritually and morally
authorized, then, to stand up.
And when I say not to back
down from any injustice,
I mean any action that threatens
peace, righteous peace.
So on the reservation,
this is part
of why I'm coming to
Google, because there
are many things that
we can do to change
the realities of reservation
life, which is a struggle,
and institute a cultural
and moral dignity,
rather than a cultural
and moral poverty.
Those are some of the--
and it starts small
in whatever I can do.
Whatever skills I have
as a lawyer, that's
part of my personal journey,
not just at Standing Rock,
but for Indian country
and for the United States.
We can do it all, and
we are capable of it.
And we're just looking to take
our place wherever we can.
So I know it's a tall order.
That's a long journey
to end poverty,
but we have to believe in it.
It's kind of like
running for Congress
in a very, very red state as
a progressive brown Native
American guy.
You have to convince yourself
that it's possible, that you
can do it, that it's for real.
And you have to show
up every single day.
But I believe that
it's possible.
I believe it's real.
I believe we're going to do it.
AUDIENCE: Chase, there are
people all over watching this
and listening to
you, who probably
want to know how they can help.
And if they go to lakotalaw.org,
we have an ongoing project,
which you are leading and
which others are leading.
And I just want to comment
that there are seven cities now
that have voted to
pull their money,
divest their money from
the big banks, which
include Wells Fargo, Bank of
America, Citicorp, US Bank.
All of them are funding the
pipelines and funding DAPL.
So there are cities
voting to divest
and trying to figure
out how to set up
public banks as alternatives
to these big banks
or going into credit
unions, et cetera.
And that information about
that program is on the site,
if people want to do that.
We've just voted
that in Santa Cruz.
But also, the pressure
that we're putting on,
the thousands of people who
are sending this petition
letter to North Dakota to get
them to drop all these charges
is really important, because the
water protectors are innocent.
The guiltiness in
terms of violence
is on the side of
the energy transfers
company and TigerSwan.
This is really wrong
that they continue
to prosecute innocent,
peaceful water protectors.
And they need to dismiss
all these charges
against everybody.
I mean, there are
trials scheduled
right now for next May.
This is an ongoing, ridiculous
legal aggressiveness
against innocent people.
So everybody should send
that letter to North Dakota.
And can you tell us,
again, what the number
is, if you want to go--
if you want to do
it on your phone,
you do what you're
saying the number is.
Or you can go to lakotalaw.org,
and send the letter right away.
It goes right to North Dakota.
CHASE IRON EYES: Yes,
thank you for that.
It is important.
We have to take a stand.
And how you help right now, the
water protector situation that
we find ourselves in, where we
are being criminalized right
now, what you do is you text
"Lakota," L-A-K-O-T-A to 64336,
or just log onto our
website, lakotalaw.org.
And there's another
website, mazaskatalks.org.
That might be confusing, because
it's another Lakota word,
M-A-Z-A-S-K-A, Talks.
It means money talks.
There is never a
time where you can't
contribute to the kind of
world that you want to create.
Every dollar you spend is a
vote for what kind of world
you want to live in.
So if we want to
justly transition
from extractive industry
coupled with big finance
and endless wars and so
forth into something that's
more renewable and regenerative
and kind of evolved,
we can do that.
It's up to us.
It's on us to compel our
leadership, our policymakers,
and so forth to take us there.
And one way you can do
that is to move your money.
You have tremendous
power and ability
to impact our path,
our trajectory.
So those are the ways that
you can continue to help.
And just link with us.
When you send us that
text, if you want,
you can give us your number.
And we won't blow up your texts.
We're only going
to text you when
we have something extremely
important that we think
is worth your time.
And each of you have networks
in here, hundreds and thousands
of people that have
very real voting power,
economic power, and so forth.
Like, we should be
determining our destiny.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I know you're having
an event in Sunnyvale tomorrow.
Will you tell people how
they can come and meet
you and participate?
CHASE IRON EYES: That's right.
So tomorrow, which is
Wednesday, September 6th,
it looks like it starts at 7:30
PM local time, Pacific time.
No, tomorrow--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHASE IRON EYES: Yeah,
tomorrow's Wednesday.
September 6th, and it's
at the Congregational
Church of Sunnyvale.
You can log onto our
website to get an address,
but 1112 South Bernardo
Avenue, Sunnyvale.
Myself and my counsel,
Daniel Sheehan,
will be there to give you
more in-depth legal updates
and kind of just contextualize
the entire history
of this struggle.
Like this struggle is not new.
We've been fighting for our
humanity and our birth rights
and our spirits, not
just as native people.
I'm talking about human beings.
We have been fighting for
our rights for a long time.
And just now, because
of Standing Rock,
we were able to share
that, to share that vision.
And it's real.
It's very, very real.
And I know that
we are seeking it,
and we'll continue
to seek it together.
AUDIENCE: Just a
quick question, Chase.
In closing, could
you give the people
that are listening
the larger context
in which this is occurring
with regard to the elephant
in the middle of the living room
of Donald Trump now ascending
to the presidency, and 180
countries around the world
having joined together
in Paris to cut back
on the use of fossil
fuels and the resolution
that this particular
administration has
come to to push forward with
the production of petroleum?
And touch upon the
entrance into this dynamic
of calling home
troops, basically,
from the Middle East in
the form of TigerSwan,
and bringing them in as
the military protection
of this administration
that is pushing forward
with the increasing of the
production of petroleum.
CHASE IRON EYES: Those
are great points.
I think we have to, again,
mention fear and hate
and division, and wherever those
concepts are being perpetrated
on us, wherever we are told
that this is your enemy, that we
need to be very, very careful,
because since the advent
of currency, since the
creation of the concept
of nation-states, since the
advent of other concepts
like private property and
so forth, we have those, who
are able to, for instance, lend
money to both sides of a war.
Those have kind of
been the determiners
of what our policy
looks like and who
we are supposed to call an
enemy, who we are supposed
to vilify, who we should
be willing to send
our sons and our
daughters to die for.
And what we are
witnessing right now,
what we will witness
in our country,
in America, where there is and
where there was a low level oil
war in the heartland
of our country,
where a private
military corporation was
able to bring to bear
the force of the arms
and institutions of the state,
a state of the union, who enjoys
the air of objectivity
and legitimacy,
they were able to instigate
them to create a boogieman.
They were able to call
us jihadists out there.
And they were able to create
this battle, this low level oil
war, and they called
it a battlefield.
They were able to make a lot
of money off of the taxpayers'
dime in North Dakota.
And what we are seeing is that
our constitutional rights,
our rights to speak freely,
our rights to peaceably
assemble, our rights
to avail ourselves
of interstate
commerce, our rights
to privacy, our rights to be
free from illegal searches
and seizures, our rights
to tell the truth,
our rights to be
whistleblowers--
those are all at risk if
the current modus operandi
of this encroachment
upon our natural birth
and constitutional
and other rights
continues in the name
of unchecked greed.
This is why I say,
capital without compassion
is uncivilized.
We have to-- this is
another play on the dynamics
they try to force.
Oh, if you're
against corporations,
you're anti-capitalists.
Well, no.
We're 100% pro-entrepreneur.
But capital without
compassion is savage.
We have to change our ethos,
because for us, it's very real.
This is a real thing.
This is not--
I could go to prison here.
And we can't let that happen.
We can't let a single water
protector serve a day in jail,
because right now,
they're coming for us.
But soon, they're going to
be coming for everybody.
We just have to be
truthful and be ready.
We don't have to engage
propaganda or hyperbole.
Let's just get the facts
out there, and make
our own informed
decisions, kind of
be our own leaders, so to speak.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]